[Music]
petty police news
oh [ __ ] submitted by pet the dog I like
to pet the dogs police spent almost $600
on DNA tests to catch the thief of a
$2.00 bottle of yogurt one waste of
[ __ ] money
it's got anymore whatever the police are
doing they're getting paved so it's like
I'll do something I think the story
itself is petty okay what city is this
in can you guess China
Orange County yeah hey no Beach has no
prior crime goona hills that they would
be this heavy enough I guess Cow Palace
that's a print that's a principle thing
that's a principle thing that's like hey
you're not supposed to be stealing okay
and I don't care like some Amish any or
some [ __ ] seriously the Asian City
Oh in Japan is in Japan no no where's
the place where do you get you can get
your arm cut off for stealing in the
Middle East the movie Aladdin in Taipei
[Laughter]
Taiwan Taitung so this woman she has
five roommate and she when she came home
one day she noticed that there was an
empty one of her yogurt bottles oh it's
a roommate situation like a grocery
store
let me tell you something I'm totally
with it my name is on my [ __ ] no that's
my yogurt you know I mean yeah she was
like no one asked me for permission or
like you know no one asked if they can
have one of my yogurt bottles so then
she started she had like an emergency
House meeting she was like oh yeah so
she was like who drink we okay no one
admitted so she ended up doing
that she took the bottle to the police
station and wanted them to do DNA tests
and she also did DNA test on all five
suspects wow that's a lot - about five
hundred eighty five billion yeah but
wait wait wait a forensic investigation
what's it what's the relationship here I
don't know they're just roommate there
must be several this [ __ ] with the cops
you can't just going out of the police
station it'd be like how would you do a
DNA check cuz I'll be like if it's this
you know she had to go in the trash can
and grab that [ __ ] thing and put it
into a plastic bag walk over there with
all of her five roommates here's the
other thing - what the [ __ ] well this
story went viral online and people were
so angry at the fact that the police
wasted their budget and time on this
Steudle she didn't have to pay for that
no she did it it was it was a police
that's some local thing you can do you
have a thing I don't know oh come on
yeah not everybody has the wherewithal
to be like okay I'm gonna do this thing
to the cops people just don't follow
through with stuff that's just somebody
that's just neurotic exactly not only
that but it's like okay you really can't
handle a roommate drinking some of your
she was fed up move out like move the
[ __ ] oh this is my dinner oh wait a bit
hold on it's like when people don't feel
the brita you know what I mean like hey
I've asked you like a bunch of times or
clean your dishes I guess like before
you take it to the step of going to the
police
you can move he'll know what you went to
the police because actually there should
just be like outside lab so you can just
go - yeah that's true yes but no money
and be like that way first of all I'm
that petty I would do that [ __ ] but you
go to some lab you could take people you
take your mice toothbrush to be like
like there was you easy dude it's like
if we live together and then you eat
some of my food fine let's just do it
that way - but I guarantee you I could
eat way more of your food than you video
oh yeah so let's play this yeah you
bought to see some [ __ ] dude you it's
gonna look like a [ __ ]
we're gonna go grocery shopping in the
next day everything you know what I'm
good I'm good at eating I'm good at
using toothpaste I'm good at using hello
I'm gonna use a conditioner exactly that
using all those but they look what we're
talking about here with this story is
like how petty are you oh I'm petty to
the [ __ ] man that's some petty [ __ ]
right there to be like I'm gonna magic
the house meeting was like okay who ate
yogurt yogurt you not gonna tell me
you're not gonna tell me okay
I'm going to the cops I'm taking this
[ __ ] here what would you all say you'd
be like go to the cops [ __ ] why it's
still in my yogurt yeah I would just buy
like a Costco size yogurt thing on my
[ __ ] do you guys want to drink my
yogurt go ahead no no no I would be like
I would tell anybody that yeah one of
the yogurt one of them I spit in I'm not
gonna tell you which one it is
I'm okay with the spit think about that
my usher brother head with the guy I put
my balls in one of these when they were
going out to eat and [ __ ] right you know
like if you go to like McDonald's or
something and you guys off the dollar
menu or you to make your homie pay you
back to that make chicken that you got
it's a dollar right you're something out
of your the audacity of this
[ __ ] I actually know this do
because we all went to church together
at the end of the month he gave my
brother an excel sheet of all the times
he spotted him Portland a townie nine
said cheeseburger no use like some some
toilet paper of toilet paper he gave him
an excel sheet my brother took it he
crumpled it up went into his room and
threw it in his face he's like [ __ ] you
didn't did it even add up to $20 he said
like the annoyed part was that when they
would go out to eat he would say I got
you you owe me three dollars and fifty
cents see this is all about how you
interact with people so like if we're
going someplace and I say hey I'll get
you one I'll get you then don't
that's mine now I mean I'm saying like
if you say you got me whatever I got
that [ __ ] is mine and don't bring it I
don't bring your [ __ ] up
but don't wait don't act like oh hey can
I have some of the hey I bought that for
you and I'm like take all your [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I don't want nothing I don't
want nothin from you
yeah you know all I can't steal like I
say like I take you out to dinner I'm
taking you to dinner and you say like or
like so much thing you do then they look
at you and go well can you get the tip
no [ __ ] that's part of dinner
yeah you said you take it me to do yeah
so no I'm not giving you the tip I'm not
paying for [ __ ] could you ask you know
if it's on you then it's on you period
this right hate you like like and girls
do this like hey just my girlfriend like
if we go on someplace and I go I see you
want something no no this my [ __ ] get
you something but I it's like like much
[ __ ] got different sauce on using it
just tastes better when you steal it the
only thing I'm selfish about with my
girl in food they can't help you shut up
literally the reverse in our
relationship I'm like you want some he's
like naw I'm good and then I get it and
because I know that his [ __ ] ass is
gonna get my food I secretly order one
on this side because I'm a hungry
[ __ ] I'm like here you go cuz I
knew you were gonna get my [ __ ] right oh
[Laughter]
yeah he gonna kidnap your kid like that
that's the only thing they like but my
girlfriend I fight about it's like being
selfish with food like we are like she
would like this or this too like if you
go to like let's say you went she went
to that place you know you better bring
me something back like don't come
walking in the house with some [ __ ] and
you don't have something for me this is
my girl just did she when she won this
place where you get like charcoal
lemonade and stuff like that so she had
a charcoal lemonade and something else
she had two things this size - I said
okay which one is mine she's like oh I
Hey these are both for me wow you know
we had a fight
I took it for myself good relationship
no no those are the expense of your
fights just about [ __ ] lemonade yeah
yeah it's a good relationship right
there true cuz I just don't like that
when it happens that way and when they
asked for something but I gave a slice
of pie and they're like oh can I just
have some but then 2/3 of its gone on
the horse again I thought what son
what's some D how about this this is
another one of my girlfriend's things
her eyes are bigger than her stomach
okay all girls are yes so she'll order
some big-ass thing right and then I'd be
like I know you're not gonna finish it
let me just have some of that then she's
like no and if she tries to finish it
out of spite
okay you want some oh my god I don't
want it now
I don't because you don't want it I
wanted you to give it to me when you
still wanted it it meant more that's the
principle of I want you to give it to me
where you want I see how you enjoying it
don't give it to me now that you're like
I can't finish you know like you're
eating and stuff and then sometimes
you're amongst good company so then
you'll like put your your utensils done
and you start engaging in a really good
conversation he goes he starts getting
the food off of my plan like what the
[ __ ] up so eating it he's like while you
put your utensils down like that means
you don't want it anymore
yes I go through three to five seconds
that's just some you don't even know
about quad move dude look if you
supposed to be eating you eating and you
stop but it's doable
one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi
the test she don't want it she don't
want
this is about quadrant that you girls
have learned this is about quad moon
right here raise your drink right he
goes hey geek after that put a whole
[ __ ] feet I've literally seen him
look at her pancakes and heap like a
tempurpedic [ __ ] mattress all the
whole thing he goes are you gonna finish
that you put your [ __ ] forensics
fingerprint on the pension be like oh my
god be eating something you did oh good
oh it's gonna have someone go for it
we'll pass him a fork right he'll slap
the fork out of my head that's why it's
bad you know what I like to do those
like you a girl like you show how like a
hamburger or something she'd be like hey
I say can have a bite you guys okay just
one bite when she says that [ __ ] I go
[Music]
[Laughter]
like a deep throat in this [ __ ]
relationship disappear too you bite so
deep all corners I like to bite the
burger where it looks like a smile
[Music]
you